[Music]
i like your hair i love the dress thank
you fantastic i made it myself you made
it yourself
are you lying you didn't fine if you're
lying i made this myself
and i made this microphone
we're liars yeah
um pretty little liars pretty little
liars
wow
megan i love it when you stop by the
show you know what's nice i like it when
uh people come by the show who i also
get to see in my regular life and and
this is true with andy too but we we all
hang out with you and your your
delightful husband mr nick offerman he
has a delay of parks and recreation fame
i think we have a run seriously
there he is in a moment of great passion
emoting uh
yeah
but you married a manly manly man yeah
he is
does he have a feminine side at all
because we're talking about a guy who
builds canoes with his bare hands
uh wrestles bears he's got that
incredible mustache uh does he have a
feminine side
there he is he's waiting for the answer
right now he is
he is more manly than most but he does
have a feminine side we have three small
poodles under 10 pounds that he you know
carouses around with and he you know i
think it's pretty much with he and i
let's like baby talk 24 7. oh when you
guys yeah
and yes we do a lot of baby talk and the
other thing is like he does occasionally
there are certain men who um
give him the gig make him giggle
he's got it's funny exactly it's funny
because he's a guy who
looks like he has that voice and that
presence and he comes into the room and
he knows how to like throw an axe 600
feet
but then he's got this giggle you've
heard it all the time too that's crazy
but you know it doesn't even belong to
that body his giggle i can't even do it
can you do his giggle
i i can't i can't really do it but it's
like a
it's like a
i'm trying to think it sounds like
popping fresh being poked in the stomach
yeah he is he is sort of like
it's like crazy that's good well you
know when i first met him when we were
first together he didn't really have a
laugh and he didn't really smile and
show teeth
i think it's something you know like i
don't know i don't know why but i mean
he was very funny and certainly like
appreciated humor but when he would
laugh it was kind of one of those like
like just look right an exhalation
through your nose yeah which is
disturbing
yeah
it's like acid reflux
and from such a funny person and then he
also like like for pictures i noticed
that he never smiled and shed teeth and
so at a certain point i was like can you
show me a smile and like let the
sunshine a little bit and he would go
he just wasn't he just wasn't raised
i wasn't raised around
were there other humans when he was
growing up no no now he wasn't he
because he is from uh he's from farm uh
he's from a big farm and did he i don't
even did he know how to dress when you
guys met well you know actually his
main the mainstay of his uh wardrobe was
a pair of yellow
overalls that he would we would go out
to dinner and he would tuck the napkin
into the bib of his overalls no he
wouldn't yes he would no one does that
no yeah he did he'd tuck the thing in
and go like i'm ready for some beach
tank and he holding
like a toothbrush yeah like this yeah
did he get real when he saw an elevator
was he scared
that's one of them moving rooms i heard
about
but like when he went away to college he
didn't even know like about the beatles
or anything like he learned everything
really late oh my god
so incredible